hey it's Evan Carmichael I've been
getting a lot of your questions and I'm
slowly and slowly falling behind on my
ability to answer everything in a timely
matter and so I thought why don't I
combine a whole bunch of these videos
together and and we'll see how it goes
so I'm gonna answer a lot of your
questions in this one video for the ask
Evan show number one and let me know
what you guys think about the format if
we should keep it dump it or do
something else
leave a comment okay so let's let's kick
it up let's start it off first question
from Doulos Z 180 good stuff
don't ever stop and success stories I
love them do you have anything on Mark
Burnett I don't have anything on Mark
Burnett yet but it's a great story I've
read his book I don't remember what it's
called but it's a great book and I think
you should watch the channel because
something soon might be coming on Mark
Burnett next up Linda B asks Evan this
is off topic but can you make a video
about how you make your videos like
which camera I'd like to use how you
make the white screen etc that'd be
really great thank you in advance if you
can do it and also thank you for your
videos in general Thank You Linda I've
done a number of videos explaining how I
do my setup it's really not that
complicated I use when I'm doing just
audio I use my my Yeti microphone here
that I bought at the MAC store when I'm
hooked right into the camera I use a
clip mic that I bought from the Sony
store for 90 bucks my camera I started
off with various cameras from Costco
because they had a long return policy
was within 30 days you could return it
and eventually outgrew that and now I
use a canon camera I forget which one it
is but I've talked about on my other
videos you know what I'm gonna take a
picture smile for the white background I
just use a white wall in my house so my
office my home office I got a white wall
I just stand up against that and I use
natural light I turn off all the lights
that I have in the room I have a big
window you want to just do it video so
that you're facing the window here in
this room I've got a light in front of
me and I've got a light beside me kind
of behind me
so it creates a little bit of a shadow
on this side but it's okay just don't
don't stand with your with your back
towards the light or it's gonna come out
really poorly one thing don't wanna
remind you guys if you're starting off
doing video don't go out and just buy
all the gear okay I've got the tripod
the two microphones now the the nice
camera that costs about $2,000 but start
with this start with this start with
this start with the laptop camera right
it doesn't have to cost you anything
make sure you love it make sure you're
having you're getting results from it
before you start investing money into
anything because you can easily spend
tons of money on inoculating return and
your camera and all your gear sits there
in the corner so I made sure that I was
loving the videos and I made I don't
know how many hundreds of videos 800
videos maybe before I even invested into
this camera so you have to make sure
that you're getting a lot of results out
of it next up is Daniel who writes in
the say the video is perfect that you
subscribe to your channel Thank You
Daniel I'd like to ask how do I find an
angel investor I went to different
websites like goose comm and others but
I'm afraid to share my business idea
which is not an idea anymore but I'm
afraid because anybody with little money
can do it I know it's going to be very
successful because it's unique anybody
can do it but it's unique and the
mission is amazing which is donating
part of the profits to help cheer their
children around the world find school
supplies for education so it's a social
entrepreneurial business so based on
this where do you think I can find the
right angel investor thanks so Daniel
first of all we got to get really clear
on your pitch you start talking angel
investors you got to be really specific
right you're saying anybody can do this
but it's unique so you're giving me a
little bit of heartburn listening to you
here with your pitch okay listen the
reality of angel investors most of them
work through informal networks they're
not going to be on websites and not
going to be advertising their profile
because they're gonna get bombarded you
got to remember most angel investors
they they have full-time jobs right
they're their dentists they're doctors
or lawyers they're entrepreneurs they
have their own businesses right so they
don't want to be inundated so they
usually work through their informal
network say they work through their
lawyers they look at their accountants
those are the people who you want to
connect with their their financial
advisors if you're dealing with
net-worth individuals these are the guys
who you want to reach out to the first
angel I met through my dentist and he
connected me to other angels and other
angels and so you want to start talking
to everybody right you want to start
talking to anybody who has those
connections in use your info on networks
and they'll start introducing you to
people but you got ever you got a you
got to make this pitch better you got to
WoW me the social aspect is great but
it's not enough right I got to know a
little bit more about what your business
is all about and yeah I mean you want to
pitch an angel investor you got to be
super specific you got to be super clear
and the best way to reach out is through
your local network all right next up
Edward Suarez who's one of my YouTube
viewers writes in the say hey Evan
my name is Edward Suarez I'm a 20 year
old college student on a small island in
the Pacific called Guam I really want to
start up a laser tag business on my
beautiful little island WOM is a small
family-oriented Island economically
driven by the tourism business locals
and tourists would love the experience
of it all there are no laser tag
facilities on the island so the laser
tag market is non-existent and I have a
great burning passion to build it but
the only way to do so is to acquire a
small business loan from a local bank
I have no assets but I believe that the
possibility of a laser tag business
would be incredible it's a small island
with very little things to do we've been
around the same malls and entertainment
facilities for many years should I take
the risk or wait for better
circumstances thank you for your time
sir Edward so great question if nobody's
doing it it's a warning sign some people
see it as an opportunity but I see it as
a warning sign because if there are
great opportunities you're probably
gonna see people jumping on them in some
way or another now I hate jumping in the
businesses on alone right it's scary you
know you don't want to be risking your
entire future on this one idea and if it
doesn't work out then what happens and
you have no assets like you're not
starting from a great place what I would
try to do is think of how can I start
this business for as low cost as
possible ideally no cost how can you
start up a partnership with somebody so
you can get this started with no cost
but think about how can you do without a
location and without staff to start it
up right so you just have the equipment
you just have the actual laser tag guns
can you partner up with another local
business can they provide you with a
space can somebody even provide you with
some of the funding if you're gonna be
running it so you're not putting your
own outlay of cash this I don't see as a
tourist attraction right I could do
laser tag here I'm not gonna come to
Guam if I'm going to Guam I'm not doing
laser tag so you've got to be something
it's gotta be selling to locals so I've
been looking at can I get enough locals
maybe you can even pre sell it right can
you go to enough locals and say hey
we're selling memberships for this laser
tag thing and if you get 100 memberships
at X amount of dollars that provides you
with the financing to go out there and
get the equipment and then you make the
partnership with some local business or
hall or whatever it is to use their
space or do special events and then
build yourself up but it's really scary
when I hear entrepreneurs say I need to
take out a loan to get equipment and pay
for staff and get a location that's a
lot of dollars and you've never done
this before and you have no you know
track record experience momentum behind
you then the chances of you failing are
gonna be pretty high and it may take
time for you to be able to build up to
get you know to the point where you're
pivoting and figuring out what the right
model is for this it's gonna take you a
little bit of time and so you don't want
to run out of cash on that path so
figure out a way to start this without
spending money spend a lot of hassle put
in your energy we're not spending money
if you can get that off the ground and
get people to support you then I think
you could be onto something if you're
really super passionate about laser tag
then let that show if everything that
you're doing next up is another YouTube
viewer Shafi who wrote in the say
sometimes it's easy to decide but very
difficult or lazy to act on my question
is how to get energy motivation to make
a decision and turn your dreams into
reality for example to study hard and so
on thanks to the answer Shafiq ah this
is the eternal question for a lot of
entrepreneurs motivation is is one of
those things that
you have to schedule in you have to
figure out a plan for it every single
day because one day you might be super
high you know you might come out of a
meeting you might come out of a seminar
feeling excited you read a book you
watch the video you're on top of the
world you're ready to go if you're
killing it you landed that deal you're
so excited you're pumped up and then the
next day you wake up and you're starting
all over again from scratch and you feel
like where did my energy go what
happened and it's such an emotional
roller coaster being an entrepreneur
that you need to schedule in and create
it you need to design your environment
to support you as an entrepreneur so
what I would do is especially in that
early days like when you first wake up
the first part of the morning what is
your schedule what is your routine what
do you do to surround yourself with that
supportive environment so the music you
listen to you know the first thing that
you check in the morning whatever task
you're working on should be something
that inspires motivates you remembering
what you're your big why is your
life-changing goal your your big purpose
your passion whatever it is remembering
you know the little Y's which are people
that you've helped recently small wins
that you've had in your business you
know all of those things help and for me
I remember when I was first starting up
my first business it was a software
company I'm making 300 bucks a month you
know barely surviving not even surviving
how do I get up every day and and go to
work and be excited and be happy and be
motivated what really helped me was one
having stories of famous entrepreneurs
that I would read regularly and reading
about Bill Gates and how he started how
he had nothing and how he was in
software and and then other people who
are outside my field if it's Oprah
Winfrey Richard Branson and these
stories you look at how they started it
was nothing people like people like you
and me started with nothing and turned
their dreams into reality and built
businesses that they can hang their hat
on say I made this I'm really proud of
what I just did that was inspiring for
me because these guys
weren't handed their success they made
it on their own so that combined with
the little wins of reminding myself of
all the people I've helped and the
conversations how people said thank you
so much Evan this is really helping me
in my life or in my work or or what you
said help change my path those things
really excited me and motivated me so
you have to remember the big why right
why are you doing this why it's
important a little wide the people that
you're supporting the small wins that
you've had create a routine the supports
in the morning surround yourself with
things that inspire and motivate you and
it's it's a daily challenge it's a daily
struggle every day you wake up and it's
a new opportunity to motivate yourself
to go out and chase your dreams and
anybody who says it's easy it just
hasn't gone through it so that's it for
ask Evan number one let me know what you
think leave a comment below you like the
format you don't like the format let me
know and subscribe to the channel see
more videos like this thank you guys so
much for watching I'll see you soon
don't forget to check out my newsletter
like blaow hi I'm Jason Grif on sigur
rós online.com and I want to say Evan
Carmichael's newsletter is consistent
fun inspiring and it's only newsletter I
prioritize and look forward to period